Maximilian Janisch, 16 Jahre.
Sein IQ liegt bei 149+.
D.h.: Er sprengt die gängige Skala.
Maximilians Leidenschaft
ist die Mathematik.
Ich verbessere gerade ein Spiel,
das ich gestern am Strand
zu programmieren begonnen habe.
Es ist eine Visualisierung
des Spiels,
das wir in der Klasse spielen.
Man ersetzt immer die Zahlen,
die durch drei teilbar sind,
und die Zahlen,
die eine Drei enthalten, durch Boom.
Ich habe eine sehr kleine Version
dieses Spiels
in Python implementiert
mit einem sehr einfachen
grafischen Interface.
Während mehrerer Stunden
am Strand gar nichts machen,
ist nicht mein Ding.
Wie lebt es sich
als höchstbegabter Jugendlicher?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
* Drollige Klänge *
Orbetello in der südlichen Toscana.
Hier verbringt Maximilian
seine Sommerferien.
Che cosa hai fatto ieri?
Ieri?
Ieri era mercoledi.
- Mercoledi.
Mercoledi ... Allora:
Dopo sono andato a scuola.
Si.
- E dopo ho pranzato.
E dopo ho ...
sono andato con i miei genitori
e ho fatto un po di matematica.
E dopo ho aspettato che Helene
arriva a Orbetello.
In dieser Sprachschule
lernt Maximilian Italienisch.
Quasi ohne Vorkenntnisse angekommen,
belegt er nach drei Wochen Unterricht
den Fortgeschrittenenkurs.
Vorbereitungen
für seine Doktorarbeit.
Es ist so, dass mein Mentor Camillo
Italiener ist,
und ich möchte bei ihm promovieren.
Laut einer neuen Regelung
der Uni Zürich
promoviert man nicht bei einem
Doktorvater, sondern bei zweien.
Mein Plan ist es,
bei ihm zu promovieren
und als zweiten Doktorvater
seinen Doktorvater zu nehmen,
Luigi Ambrosio.
Ich würde also bei zwei italie-
nischen Professoren promovieren.
Ich denke,
dann ist es kein Nachteil,
wenn ich
ein bisschen Italienisch spreche.
Einige Studenten und Assistenten an
der Uni Zürich sind auch Italiener.
Italienischkenntnisse
schaden also nicht.
Cinquantanove.
Maximilian brilliert,
wenn es um Zahlenspiele geht.
Und er hat sich bestens in seine
temporäre Schulklasse integriert.
No! Bravo, Max.
Bravissimo.
84! Das hat es noch nie gegeben
in der Geschichte unserer Schule.
Er passt sich jeder Situation an.
Das gefällt mir am besten.
Er kann die banalsten Gespräche
mit anderen Teenagern führen.
Andererseits beschäftigt er sich
mit absolut aussergewöhnlichen
und komplizierten Themen.
Und das auf einem Niveau, das andere
Jugendliche gar nicht interessiert.
Seine Intelligenz beschränkt sich
nicht auf die Mathematik,
er hat einen viel breiteren Horizont
als Gleichaltrige.
Er weiss wirklich viel
für sein Alter.
Es ist schön,
sich mit ihm auseinanderzusetzen.
Maximilian ist mit seinen 16 Jahren
der jüngste Student der Schweiz.
Von alldem haben
seine Mitschüler in der Sprachschule
erst beim Erscheinen
der Fernsehkamera erfahren.
O mein Gott, ich bin jetzt neu ...
Ich finde es cool,
dass er nicht sein ganzes Leben
auf dieses "Ich bin so gut in Mathe"
ausrichtet,
sondern sich immer noch gerne
auch für andere Sachen interessiert
und die dann gut fördert.
Wir sprechen z.B. viel
übers Programmieren und Codieren.
Und Hardware.
- Und Hardware.
Da habt ihr euch also gefunden?
- Schon, sehr.
Welche Themen interessieren
euch beide sonst noch?
Hardware und Software
ist schon ziemlich gross.
Aber z.B. Robotik, also alles
in Richtung Computer Science.
Informatik ist das Fachgebiet,
über das wir beide
ein bisschen was wissen.
Höchstbegabungen
wie die von Maximilian sind selten.
Bei entsprechender Förderung
resultiert daraus ein Phänomen,
das fasziniert und polarisiert.
Wir haben eins eingesetzt.
Dann steht da ...
Hier steht 1 + ... x2 ist ja 1.
Kosinus von Pi y ist Kosinus von Pi.
Der Kosinus ist bei 2 Pi eins.
D.h., bei Pi
sind meines Erachtens null.
Ne, da ist ja minus eins.
- Richtig, minus eins.
Mit neun Jahren
kam Maximilian in die Schlagzeilen,
weil er an der ETH studieren wollte.
Diese lehnte ab.
... eins gesetzt. Dann steht da ...
... von x y z.
- X y z.
Wir sind hier gerade
beim Differenzieren
mehrdimensionaler Funktionen -
meistens zweidimensional.
Auf welcher Stufe
wird das unterrichtet?
Ja, im ... das ist meines Erachtens
zweites Semester. Oder drittes?
Zweites Semester.
Das ist die Abschlussprüfung
des zweiten Semesters von ...
2014.
Das ist die letzte Abschlussprüfung.
Und das ist kein Problem für dich?
Diese spezielle Aufgabe nicht,
andere schon.
Da fühlen wir uns fast veralbert.
- Ja.
Maximilian absolvierte
die Primarschule in drei Jahren.
Mit neun hatte er
die Mathematik-Matur in der Tasche,
und als Elfjähriger
kam er in den Genuss
eines auf ihn
zugeschnittenen Förderprogramms
an der Universität Zürich.
X ist aber f hoch minus eins
der Stelle f von x.
Okay? Also,
wenn du das einfach y nennst ...
Du hast genau diese Sache
von der einen und der anderen Seite.
Die Begabung von Maximilian
ist aussergewöhnlich.
Ich habe noch nie jemanden gesehen,
der in diesem Alter
die Höhe der Mathematik so gut
wie Maximilian verstehen kann.
Meiner Erfahrung nach
ist er eine ganz grosse Ausnahme.
Alle zwei Wochen reiste Maximilian
damals aus dem luzernischen
Meierskappel nach Zürich
und schloss
nebenbei das Gymnasium ab.
Each lambda that's the part of s
times the sum of j 1 ...
Seit einem Jahr ist Maximilian
regulärer Student
an der Universität Zürich
und heute im dritten Semester
seines Mathematikstudiums.
Seine Mitstudierenden,
vor denen er hier einen Vortrag hält,
sind schon zwei bis drei Jahre länger
an der Uni als er.
... into the exponent as seen here.
Right?
So if we just adjust c to be
something like -1 over y ...
Im Gymnasium hat mich v.a.
die Mathematik interessiert,
aber sie war
nicht so interessant wie hier.
Hier kann ich mich
auf die Mathematik spezialisieren.
Hier kann ich genau das machen,
was mich interessiert.
Der Fall Maximilian
bewegte die Universität Zürich dazu,
das Pilotprojekt Schülerstudium
für besonders begabte Gymnasiastinnen
und Gymnasiasten zu starten.
Maximilians Förderung war anders -
gezielt auf ihn zugeschnitten.
Dafür will er sich in diesem Film
bei der Universitätsleitung bedanken.
Maximilian, herzlich willkommen!
- Herr Hengartner, wie geht's?
Parallel zu Zürich studiert
Maximilian auch in Perpignan.
Dort konnte er sich schon mit zwölf
immatrikulieren.
Die Uni Zürich nahm ihn erst letztes
Jahr als regulären Studenten auf.
Zuwarten
war die richtige Entscheidung,
sagt Rektor Michael Hengartner.
Ich werde dieses oder nächstes Jahr
den Bachelor machen
und dann hier
mit dem Master weitermachen.
Vielleicht werde ich auch
in Perpignan weiterstudieren.
Respekt, sehr schön!
Mathe macht also immer noch Freude?
Sie macht immer noch
sehr viel Freude.
Mir war wichtig, dass seine mathe-
matische Begabung gefördert wird.
Das haben wir sichergestellt.
Das Gymnasium ist nicht nur
für die Hochschulreife da,
sondern auch
für eine gesellschaftliche Reife.
Und diese braucht halt ihre Zeit.
Es ist so, dass Menschen, die in
gewissen Bereichen sehr begabt sind,
in anderen Bereichen
dem Durchschnitt entsprechen.
Es kommt auch vor, dass Hochbegabte
auf der sozialen Stufe
mehr Schwierigkeiten haben
als der Durchschnitt.
Deshalb wollten Maximilian
nicht aus dem System nehmen,
sondern ihn begleiten und fördern.
Wir legten aber auch Wert darauf,
dass er sich
in seinem vertrauten Umfeld
persönlich weiterentwickeln kann.
Und wie wirkt er jetzt auf Sie?
- Mission accomplished.
Schon jetzt gibt es
Interessenten aus der Industrie,
die von Maximilians mathematischen
Fähigkeiten profitieren möchten.
So ist es zu einer Zusammenarbeit
zwischen der LCA,
einem KMU im Bereich Entwicklung und
Bau von Sondermaschinen, gekommen.
Maximilian soll Programme
zur Prozessoptimierung entwickeln.
Mir würde es
am meisten Spass machen,
wenn Maximilian
bei uns etwas bewegen könnte.
Und es wäre schön,
wenn andere dadurch auch sehen,
dass die Industrie
gar nicht so uncool ist
und es auch hier spannende Aufträge
und sehr interessante
und schwierige Aufgaben gibt.
Es sollte auch messbar sein,
sodass man z.B. sagen kann:
"Dank Maximilians Einsatz
konnten wir den Energieverbrauch
einer Produktion
um 15 oder 20 % senken."
Wenn man an diesem Roboter
gearbeitet hat,
hat man sofort eine Visualisierung
seiner eigenen Arbeit.
Man sieht sofort, was man
mit seiner Arbeit geschaffen hat.
Bei der Mathe
ist das nicht direkt so.
Dort hat man z.B.
ein abstraktes Theorem
das nur schwer zu visualisieren ist
und nur wenige Leute verstehen.
Aber hier braucht man
kein Vorwissen in Robotik,
um zu verstehen, warum das cool ist.
Und das ist natürlich der Vorteil
von so einer Sache.
Wissenschaft
oder angewandte Forschung -
seine langfristigen Ziele
kennt Maximilian noch nicht.
Hauptsache Mathematik.
Ich bin jetzt an der Uni Zürich
und auch an der Uni Perpignan.
Zusätzlich bin ich noch hier,
am LCA bzw. CSEM.
Hier ist es schon etwas entspannter
als am Gymnasium,
denn hier kann ich Sachen machen,
die mir wirklich gefallen.
"An die Uni mit zehn? Kein Problem!"
Zusammen mit seinem Vater
verfasste Maximilian vor vier Jahren
seine Autobiografie
auf Französisch und Deutsch.
Im Zentrum: der Kampf der Familie um
eine adäquate Förderung Maximilians.
Die Hauptbotschaft des Buches
könnte man wie folgt bezeichnen:
Die besonderen Talente -
z.B. im Sport, Tanz
oder in der Musik -
werden in der Schweiz
tatsächlich ausreichend gefördert.
Es gibt, wenn ich das
richtig in Erinnerung habe,
23 Sportgymnasien in der Schweiz.
Die besonderen Talente
in den MINT-Fächern -
Mathematik, Informatik
Naturwissenschaften und Technik -
haben diese Möglichkeit nicht.
Unsere Zuschauer
mögen vielleicht denken:
"Lasst doch diesen Jungen im Wald
herumrennen oder Fussball spielen."
Aber das interessiert ihn
schlicht nicht.
Nein, das interessiert ihn
wirklich nicht.
Wir haben ihm natürlich
alle Möglichkeiten geboten,
wir liessen ihn
an allen Veranstaltungen
wie Fastnacht oder
Kindergeburtstagen teilnehmen.
In der Umgebung hat es genügend
Kinder und auch einen Wald.
Wir haben versucht,
alle Möglichkeiten auszuschöpfen
und dieses Angebot zu machen,
aber er hat es nicht angenommen.
Das muss man akzeptieren,
man kann ihn nicht zwingen.
Für eine Buch-Promotionstour
reiste Maximilian
vor vier Jahren mit seinem Vater,
der noch vier erwachsene Kinder
aus erster Ehe hat, nach Paris.
Tom, hier hat's ein "Asterix"!
Jetzt aber los!
Den da habe ich noch nicht.
Den habe ich, den auch.
Das habe ich noch nicht.
(Reporterin)
"Asterix" liest du gerne?
Ja, das kann man sagen.
Was findest du so toll daran?
Der Text ist humorvoll
und die Zeichnungen sind schön.
Ich dachte, dass du eher
dicke Romane lesen würdest.
Ne, das ist nicht mein Ding.
- "Asterix" eher.
Sie haben noch vier andere Kinder.
- So ist es.
Unterscheidet sich diese Vaterschaft
nicht fundamental von den anderen?
Zunächst unterscheidet sich ...
Ich sage mal,
der Mindset der Gesellschaft.
Was wir jetzt machen,
wäre damals als abscheuliches eli-
täres Gehabe klassifiziert worden.
Früher konnte man nicht
an eine Schule gehen und sagen:
"Der Bursche langweilt sich. Darf
er nicht eine Klasse überspringen?"
Aber ich hatte auch eine Frau,
die gegen das Leistungsprinzip war.
Sie achtete mehr darauf,
dass es für die Jugendlichen -
früher für die Kinder -
wirklich ein Leben
mit vielen Glücksmomenten ist.
Ich selbst bin anders.
Was heisst das, Sie sind anders?
Sie wollen ja auch ein Leben
mit vielen Glücksmomenten.
Ja, aber ich empfinde das Glück
am meisten,
wenn man mit aller Kraft,
die man zur Verfügung hat,
zu einem Ergebnis gekommen ist, der
Augenblick der völligen Erschöpfung.
Das ist für Sie Glück?
- Ja.
Ist das für Maximilian auch so?
- Ja, das denke ich, ja.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Während seines Sprachaufenthaltes
in Orbetello
lebt Maximilian
bei einer Gastfamilie.
Seine temporären Eltern
sind voll des Lobes
über den aussergewöhnlichen
Jugendlichen aus der Schweiz.
Was schön ist: Er hört zu.
Normalerweise hören Jugendliche
Erwachsenen nicht zu,
aber er hört zu.
Er beobachtet,
er prägt sich alles ein.
Das ist gut.
Er ist aber kein Besserwisser.
Er weiss viel, weil er zuhört.
Maximilian ist ein Junge,
wie ihn alle Mütter haben möchten.
Er ist gut erzogen,
intelligent, anständig, fleissig.
Und er ist genau.
Genau heisst: Er hält
in seinem Zimmer perfekt Ordnung.
Keiner der anderen Jungs -
ich habe den ganzen Sommer über
Jungs aus der Sprachschule hier ...
Aber ihn,
ihn möchte ich immer hier haben.
Und er ist hübsch.
Schöne Augen, ein schöner Mund.
Bella bocca.
E bello, bello, bello, bello.
Maximilian, was machen
all diese Komplimente mit dir?
Ich habe sehr gute Noten gekriegt,
das freut mich natürlich.
Nur braun ist er nicht geworden.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Seit Maximilian einen Griffel
in der Hand halten kann,
treffen sich Vater und Sohn
zur täglichen Stunde
"Mathe für Maximilian".
Ein kleiner Dämpfer war,
dass Maximilian auf seinen Bachelor
noch ein Jahr warten muss -
wegen einer krankheitshalber
zu spät eingereichten Arbeit.
Heute diskutieren Vater und Sohn
mögliche Themen für die Masterarbeit.
Camillo hat mir
mehrere Vorschläge gemacht,
die in Richtung Euler-Gleichung
gehen.
Ich weiss noch nicht, welches Thema
ich für die Masterarbeit nehme.
Für den Master brauche ich
vermutlich regulär drei Semester.
Meine Promotion möchte ich dann
in Princeton abschliessen.
Ich werde ein Jahr in Zürich machen
und die letzten beiden Jahre
in Princeton.
An diesem provisorischen Plan
kann sich aber noch viel ändern.
Thomas Drisch
ist Mathematik-Professor im Ruhestand
und Förderer
seines hochbegabten Sohnes.
Diese Rollen könnten allerdings
schon bald umgekehrt sein.
Er hat mich überflügelt.
Was ich beitragen kann,
ist der Tatbestand,
dass ich eine breite
mathematische Ausbildung habe.
... dass du viel mehr weisst.
- Ich weiss viel mehr.
Das kann ich dann auch wiedergeben,
und zwar so,
dass es viel verständlicher ist
als in einem Lehrbuch.
Das lässt sich mündlich
besser machen.
Aber jetzt z.B.
diese Masterarbeit ...
Die dazu notwendigen ...
... sagen wir mal ...
speziellen technischen Verfahren -
die Mathematik baut ja Kathedralen -
aber dazu gibt es auch Maschinen,
die diese geistigen Kathedralen
erbauen.
Also diese technischen Verfahren,
die kenne ich nicht.
Und ich habe schwere Zweifel,
ob ich noch die Kraft habe,
sie zu erlernen.
- Ich denke, er ...
In dem Sinne
ist er mir schon voraus.
Thomas wird mir sicher mein ganzes
Leben lang etwas beibringen können.
V.a. bei der Mathe hat man jeden Tag
sehr viel zu lernen.
* Fröhliche Musik *
So, und action!
Maximilians Sprachaufenthalt
neigt sich dem Ende zu.
In der letzten Woche
sind seine Eltern angereist,
um einige Tage zusammen mit ihrem
Sohn in der Toskana zu verbringen
und ihn anschliessend
mit zurück in die Schweiz zu nehmen.
Also, wir sind jetzt hier
in Ansedonia.
Das ist ein kleiner Ort
nicht weit entfernt von Tarquinia.
Tarquinia ist
eine der grossen Ausgrabungsstätten,
was die Etrusker betrifft.
Etruskische Grabfelder,
Kirchenbesuche
zusammen mit den Eltern -
die meisten anderen 16-Jährigen
würden bei einem
solchen Ferienprogramm
wahrscheinlich Reissaus nehmen.
In deinem Buch hast du geschrieben,
dass du die Pubertät wahrscheinlich
einfach auslässt. Machst du das?
Ich denke,
diese Prognose war richtig.
Wie geht das?
Das ist einfach so.
Ich kann nur sagen, dass ich
keine grossen Schwierigkeiten habe,
auch wenn viele das Gegenteil
vorausgesagt hatten.
Die Frage ist ja immer,
wie man Pubertät definiert:
Hormonschwankungen, Freudlosigkeit,
Lustlosigkeit, Launenhaftigkeit-
Wenn man das hinlänglich
unter Pubertät versteht -
Rebellion gegen die Eltern -
dann bekomme ich von dem
gar nichts mit. Gar nichts.
Ich habe einen sehr, sehr
charmanten, umgänglichen,
liebenswürdigen Sohn,
der mich auf Augenhöhe behandelt
und mich ernst nimmt -
und umgekehrt.
Ich habe eigentlich wirklich immer
meine grosse Freude an ihm.
Ich finde,
er ist ein pflegeleichter Sohn.
Als Neunjähriger hatte Maximilian
seine Eltern
als seine besten Freunde bezeichnet.
Meine Beziehung zu meinen Eltern
ist immer noch sehr eng.
Ich war damals vielleicht etwas
unvorsichtig mit dieser Bezeichnung,
denn das suggeriert,
dass ich keine Freunde habe.
Das ist natürlich nicht der Fall.
Ich vermeide jetzt bewusst
die Bezeichnung beste Freunde,
aber meine Beziehung
ist immer noch formidabel.
Maximilian und seine Eltern -
ein eingeschworenes Team.
Alle drei kümmern sich wenig darum,
was andere von ihnen denken.
Angstfreiheit - das hätten ihm
seine Eltern mit auf den Weg gegeben,
sagt Maximilian.
In gewisser Weise
haben sie mich so erzogen,
dass ich weniger Angst habe
z.B. in der Gesellschaft,
dass ich keine Angst habe,
von der Norm abzuweichen,
etwas Spezielles zu machen,
mit 16 an die Uni zu gehen.
Also das ist für mich ...
Ich denke,
dass viele Angst davor haben,
sie haben Angst,
von der Norm abzuweichen.
Ich hoffe,
dass ich ihnen durch diesen Film
ein wenig die Angst nehmen kann,
dass ich sagen kann:
"Das kann Erfolg haben."
Das ist das Ziel.